[Musique]
un bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 c'est le tour
d'horizon de l'actualité locale et
régionale tout de suite les titres de ce
jeudi 14 mars le ministre de l'éducation
nationale dans les yvelines ce matin
jean michel blanquer air s'est rendu
notamment à la selle déborde dans le
cadre de la semaine des mathématiques
est l'occasion de défendre son projet de
loi pour une école de la confiance qui
prévoit l'abaissement de l'instruction
obligatoire à 3 ans un événement ce
samedi à versailles le premier salon
talents de femmes se déroule à l'hôtel
de ville expo vente animations
conférences pour partager un savoir
faire féminin s'est organisée par le
soroptimist club de versailles elle nous
recevons sa présidente lorenza malaise à
bâle rooney est notre deuxième invité le
musicien jazz de l'année baptiste herbin
a reçu en février le prix django
reinhardt plus haute distinction en
france de ce genre musical et le
saxophoniste de 31 ans est également
professeur au conservatoire de
rambouillet depuis quatre ans le
ministre de l'éducation nationale jean
michel blanquer air était donc en
déplacement ce matin dans les yvelines
il s'est rendu dans une école de l'a7
déborde une visite dans le cadre de la
semaine des mathématiques avec pour
ambition également de défendre
l'importance de l'instruction
obligatoire dès trois ans le reportage
d'aurélie ronces dans cette classe de
petite et moyenne sections de la celle
les bordes on apprend à compter à faire
de la musique ou encore à faire des
constructions sans être perturbés par la
présence de jean michel blanquer air
avec ce déplacement le ministre de
l'éducation nationale a voulu montrer le
caractère majeur de l'école maternelle
une mesure qu'il défend dans le projet
de loi sur l'école de la confiance
adopté en février dernier en première
lecture par l'assemblée nationale par
les d'instruction obligatoire à 3 ans
c'est tout simplement dire que oui
l'école commence à trois ans et que
les premières années il faut les prendre
très au sérieux il faut y aller il faut
certes le faire au travers de jeux de
musique de chose qui corresponde à cette
école de la confiance dont je parle
souvent cette école compte 87 élèves de
la petite section au cm2 et joue un rôle
clé dans ce territoire rural des
yvelines c'est ce qu'a voulu réaffirmer
l'équipe enseignante lors d'une table
ronde
ici on est une famille que ce soit les
parents les enseignants la municipalité
tout le monde travaille ensemble on se
connaît tous et c'est vraiment quelque
chose de très important dans le cadre de
la semaine des mathématiques jean michel
blanquer a également voulu souligner
l'importance de cette matière à l'école
et ce dès le plus jeune âge celui-ci
s'est retrouvé à une petite bille dans
le
dans le sac est nommé le nom et après
retrouver le maillot qui est accroché et
qui face cachée quand tous les maillots
sont retournés celui qui a le plus du be
a gagné un exercice ludique qui
visiblement plaît aux enfants avec 7 aux
écoles de la confiance et sa mesure
phare d'instruction obligatoire dès 3
ans le ministre de l'éducation nationale
a réaffirmé sa volonté de lutter contre
les inégalités sociales et il était
porté notamment par le gouvernement le
grand débat national arrive à son terme
partout en france dans le département
quelques dernières réunions et notamment
ce jeudi soir à rambouillet est la
députée la république en marche
aurore bergé entend élaborer une
synthèse des propositions avec les
participants est la députée porte parole
du mouvement se dit satisfaite de ces
échanges écoutez la au micro de wilfrid
richy clair et non j'ai organisé on
était entre 120 et 150 personnes à
chaque fois
ce qui est quand même intéressante avec
des classes d'âge assez variés alors
c'est vrai qu'il a une
sous-représentation des moins de 30 ans
pour moi il ya eu deux vertus majeur au
brandela la première c'est que on area
presse parlée à s'écouter ce n'était pas
une évidence qu'il ya quelques semaines
plus tard et injecte aussi de la
complexité c'est à dire qu'on voit bien
qu'on aborde des questions par exemple
qu'on dit je veux qu'ils aient plus de
justice fiscale où je veux qu'il ait
plus de justice sociale
bon finalement on est tous d'accord sur
ces principes sauf qu'ensuite on ne met
pas les mêmes choses pour certains plus
de justice fiscale c'est de dire il faut
que tout le monde contribue à l'impôt
sur le revenu pour d'autres au contraire
c'est dire maintenant ça n'a pas de sens
de faire contribuer les plus bas revenus
nos voiliers servent à rien j'ai traîne
un peu de complexité dans le débat pour
voir que c'est pas si simple d'arriver à
arbitrer entre les différentes
propositions et pour le gouvernement
désormais il faudra arbitrer dans les
prochaines semaines en attendant la
conférence régionale citoyenne ile de
france se tiendra ce vendredi et samedi
au grand palais à paris autre bilan
celui du plan vélo régional d'île de
france a présenté cette semaine les
premiers résultats de cette mesure votée
en mai 2010 est l'objectif affiché faire
du vélo un moyen de transport du
quotidien les détails avec ce sujet de
nos confrères de via grand paris
partir au travail tous les jours en vélo
en ile de france
la route est encore longue alors que
deux tiers des déplacements font moins
de trois kilomètres seulement 2 % des
trajets quotidiens se font en vélo la
région a déjà investi plus de 64
millions depuis 2016 au total 100
millions d'euros seront investis
objectif tripler le nombre de
déplacements quotidiens effectués en
bicyclette d'ici 2021
donc on est très en retard or le vélo
c'est le seul moyen de transport 100%
protecteurs de l'environnement et 100%
bon pour la santé
donc il faut le développer et pour cela
nous avons construit en trois ans près
de 600 km soit deux pistes cyclables
soient de piste partager vélos voitures
l'objectif c'est qu'il nous amène au
travail et qu'ils soient dans les
déplacements du quotidien pour que le
trajet vélo devienne un réflexe pour les
franciliens
la région compte aussi sur son service
de location longue durée de vélos
électriques
il sera lancé en septembre prochain
coûtera 40 euros par mois dont la moitié
remboursés par l'employeur dans
l'actualité une tentative d'évasion
avortée à la maison d'arrêt de bois
d'arcy deux jeunes détenus ont écopé de
peines de huit et douze mois de prison
prononcée par le tribunal correctionnel
de versailles courant février
ils ont réussi à découper l'un des bars
ou de leur fenêtre avec ce morceau de
métal les individus ont creusé un trou
dans leur cellule donnant directement
sur la cour de promenade
le projet a été découvert par les
surveillants lors d'une inspection ces
deux personnes étaient incarcérées à
bois d'arcy pour des vols en bande
organisée et association de malfaiteurs
une première édition à versailles le
salon talents de femmes se tient ce
samedi c'est de 10h à 19h à l'hôtel de
ville on en parle avec vous lorenza
malaise baronne et bonsoir bonsoir merci
d'être présente ici alors vous êtes la
présidente de soroptimist du soroptimist
club de versailles qui organise cet
événement sont optimistes c'est une ong
qui est présente dans 123 pays à 66
soixante seize mille membres à travers
la planète trois mille clubs dans le
monde
qu'est ce que c'est son optimiste alors
le céramiste club
c'est une ong bien entendu à créditer
aussi à l'onu est on est on voit pour
les femmes qui ont défense justement
tous les droits de la femme et des les
filles dans l'environnement dans
l'éducation dans l'entrepreneuriat on à
divers différents des vise donc un trait
prendre comprendre et défendre
donc c'est un challenge différent au
thème celui de l'entrepreneur mais
virtuellement exactement il n'y a pas
que la femme qui travaille mais on est
vraiment on
on est vraiment on défend l'éducation de
la femme et des filles
on a mis en avant le leadership au
féminin
on est on défende de la paix dans le
monde entier et on met à l'avant surtout
aussi bien entendu l'éducation parce que
ce à travers l'éducation que bien
entendu et on aura un monde meilleur
alors cela fait quelques mois que vous
êtes président du club de versailles qui
a lui 80 ans d'existence est un club
bien ancrée dans cette ville de
versailles exactement donc est pour
faire un petit peu en
petit résumé et c'est une un mouvement
qu'il était créée en 1921 aux états unis
en france il est arrivé à 1924 et
c'était le docteur susan ol là que
c'était la première femme chirurgie
esthétique et qui répare et les gueules
cassées pour pendant la première guerre
mondiale
et pour la suite à versailles c'est 1937
qui s'était créé le premier club dont 80
ont deux ans d'existence dont on est
aussi on fait un petit clin d'oeil à la
fondation lanières que c'était aux
femmes versaillaise qu'elles étaient
marchands des chocolats dans la rue de
la paroisse et qu'il a fait don des tous
ses biens à la soeur optimiste
internacional pour les familles en
difficulté le seul objectif que beaucoup
d'événements ont donc souffre énormément
les événements et des actions à hacker
on partage aussi avec d'autres
associations qui sont dans les yvelines
pour que ce qui concerne versailles
alors là cette action inconscient de
l'entrepreneuriat pourquoi crise cet
événement sous salon talents de femmes
alors salon des deux femmes c'est un
événement qui est déjà un france son nom
79 club et tous les ans ils font talons
des femmes
voilà c'est toujours un petit peu avec
un clin d'oeil dès le 8 mars et des lada
dont claude elle assumait le droit de
former exactement et chaque mairie met à
disposition justement à la possibilité
de faire venir des femmes dans
l'entreprenariat ou d'un des métiers
complètement qui sont un petit peu dans
l'ombre et on peut mal connue pour
justement valorisé ces femmes et mettre
en avant leur métier il s'est dit
intéressé tout de suite la mairie de
versailles le fait que vous accueille
parce que on annick bouquay justement
les dans la mairie de versailles et
quinoa région il ya quelques temps dans
notre association et mazières il nous a
tout de suite donné gracieusement
devient vraiment tout de suite elle a
adhéré à notre à notre projet c'est
essentiel aujourd'hui de mettre en avant
ces femmes de ses talons le fun c'est
extrêmement important parce qu'à travers
ses talents des femmes mais justement on
peut mettre en avant des femmes qui est
parfois ils sont un petit peu dans
l'ombre dans leur métier qui osent pas
aller en avant et d'ailleurs on à la
participation le partenariat de
cathérine marché qui il a fondé bouge ta
boîte sur les yvelines et qui y va
mettre aussi l en avant les métiers de
ce réseau d'un trait perline arrière des
femmes alors d'une cinquantaine
d'exposants qui seront présentes sur
place qui sont ces femmes c'est des
thématiques très variées qui seront
proposées sur place leurs talents des
femmes c'est vraiment les talents des
femmes donc que ça pourrait être edin
l'architecte à celle qui va créer les
bijoux à l'avocat à des mythes et
complètement petit peu atypique entre
guillemets et on les met en avant donc
c'est vraiment tous les métiers tous les
métiers confondus de la femme est
pas simplement de la femme dans tous les
métiers qui on va me faire entreprendre
donc on a ces 53 exposants on est très
fiers on a malheureusement dû refuser
aussi d'autres exposants parce que en
haillons très bon succès et ses salons
il est gratuit je tiens à le dire donc
et surtout venez voir ces femmes avec ce
talent et on a demandé juste à les
exposants de faire un petit don parce
que le
mois d'octobre on rêvait resserra les
dons à l'association vivre ensemble qui
va tenir la dictée des cités au château
de versailles dans la salle des
batailles et pour mille enfants qui sont
de la région de paris qui sont
défavorisés justement pour mettre un
vent aussi la dictée et l'écriture il
nous reste une minute sur le programme
donc on a parlé de ses exposants il y
aussi d un programme de conférences tout
à fait on fait des télex l'après midi
donc à 14h30 les rentes et d'aix como
monter sa boîte à 15h30 il ya leadership
au féminin et à 16h30 ce sera bmp qu'il
donne
des aides pour éventuellement les
investissements pour des jeunes
créatrices des jeunes femmes qu'ils ont
envie de monter leur entreprise
qu'est ce que vous en attendez de cette
première édition qu'est ce qu'ils
feraient que ce soit par dont une
réussite pour moi ce serait en réussite
essayé on va justement avoir est tous
les ans ces salons et qui excelle sur le
vieux exactement qui s'installe sur la
ville et je pense que nos élus de la
région des yvelines ils vont nous suivre
et sûrement ils vont nous vous nous
donner accès à cette aventure à cette
très belle aventure et surtout dire à
tout le monde
venez voir ces femmes merci lorenza
malaise ballonné président du
soroptimist club de versailles le
premier salon talents de femmes se tient
ce samedi de 10 heures à 19 heures
c'était l'hôtel de ville de versailles
et l'entrée est libre vous l'avez
précisé dans cet entretien
cette exposition photo et justement
consacré à des femmes victoire est à
voir à la bibliothèque universitaire de
saint quentin en yvelines à guyancourt à
l'occasion de sa semaine de l'égalité
2019 l'université à paris saclay a
choisi la thématique sport et genre
découverte de ces étudiantes et
championne sportive qui lutte contre les
stéréotypes avec manon varaldo et
patrick jacques de dixmude une
exposition avec des photos réalisées par
vincent mon gorges est porteuse de
messages pour dénoncer lutter contre les
stéréotypes et ouvrira la réflexion sur
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
dans le cadre de la journée
internationale des droits des femmes et
de la semaine sur l'égalité et la parité
la bibliothèque universitaire de
guyancourt a répondu présentes en
accueillant cette exposition portraits
de jeunes femmes étudiantes de
l'université paris saclay également
championne sportive dans différentes
disciplines
rugby football mais aussi lancer de
marteau
elles sont représentées avec
l'exposition victoire pour célébrer la
semaine de l'égalité 2019 victoire 7-1
en famille
et puis victoire aussi parce qu'elles
gagnent parce que c'est des gagnants
parce qu'elles se sont surpassés elles
ont également pu allier leur vie de
jeune femme tout en gardant leur
féminité également tout en poursuivant
des carrières universitaires et en
obtenant des résultats aussi haut que
les hommes ce sont vraiment de
véritables athlètes ce parti au féminin
le sport féminin ne représente que sept
pour cent du volume global des
retransmissions sportives alors qu'une
majorité des français de plus de 18 ans
considère que le sport féminin est aussi
intéressant que le sport masculin
une exposition à la bibliothèque de
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines
à découvrir jusqu'au 27 mars et noté que
ce vendredi à plusieurs de ces sportifs
photographier pour l'exposition seront à
la bibliothèque universitaire de
guyancourt rendez vous aux alentours de
12h15
quelques heures avant de 10h à 12h à
l'ufr des sciences de la santé simone
veil à montigny le bretonneux une
conférence les femmes dans le sport de
haut niveau victoire et défis un
événement animé par la socialiste oriane
anaïs beaumont en présence de plusieurs
personnalités la volleyeuse fantine
agatha la présidente du club de volley
féminin du stade français zélia marc
l'ancien athlète et joueuses de rugby
lors herbert sans pieri enfin la
consultante foot chez canal+ à l'inria
ex joueuse de l'équipe de france de
football sur ce plateau à présent
baptiste herbin bonsoir bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous saxophoniste professeur
au conservatoire de rambouillet vous
avez reçu le mois dernier le prix django
reinhardt à la scène musicale alors
c'est une distinction accordée par
l'académie du jazz depuis 1955
une distinction notamment pour lé jeune
grands talents du jazz michel portal
richard galliano ou encore michel
petrucciani ont reçu ce prix avant vous
du coup est ce que c'est un honneur pour
nous de recevoir le prix un grand
honneur puisque on fait partie
maintenant un peu de l'histoire tu
voyais aussi des amis des gens avec qui
j'ai l'honneur de jouer comme ce samedi
avec alain jean-marie alors
et je vois qu'au 6 à u
essentiellement cette saxophoniste
depuis les années 50 qui ont reçu ce
prix prestigieux donc c'est bien de
faire partie de cette petite famille et
puis c'est un coup de boost ça permet de
l'intérieur voilà d'aller un peu plus
loin et et ça permet d'avoir un peu plus
de crédibilité par rapport à la scène et
au festival et au club alors même si
vous avez à vous il me semble que vous
ne connaissiez pas ce prix c'est ça au
départ j'avais déjà entendu parler mais
je ne savais pas vraiment à quoi cela
correspondait et notamment l'histoire et
le poids qu'avait cette institution qui
remettait ce prix prestigieux
alors avant de parler avec vous de votre
carrière on va écouter on va vous
écouter sur scène en quartet avec cet
extrait avec vous eduardo farias gérard
portal et ali jackson c'était au new
morning à paris si on écoute
[Musique]
m
alors baptiste herbin même si vous
enseignez à rambouillet vous êtes natif
de chartes vous avez 31 ans votre style
est ce que c'est plutôt du jazz
classique moderne
je prendrai mes racines dans le jazz
traditionnel c'est-à-dire le jazz des
années 40 50 et 60 c'est à dire le be
bop le hard bop qui pour moi est la base
de tout ce langage qu'on a jusqu'à
aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
même je m'intéresse aux musiques
brésiliennes à tout ce qui est un peu
funky j'ai aussi un projet qui s'appelle
herbin play ce derby donc c'est la
musique d'herbie hancock
on va dire aujourd'hui ce jazz se teinte
c'est ça je mélange il se teinter puis
avec toutes les autres cultures je peux
aussi jazz malgache c'est à dire allié
avec la rencontre avec la musique
traditionnelle malgache c'est sans fin
donc 2 mais en prenant ses racines vers
les harmonies et la musique le
répertoire de du jazz plus
traditionnelle on arrive après à créer
c'est infiniment de musique donc je suis
plutôt dans ce circuit
je dirais à devenir du jazz plus
populaires et traditionnelles et
classiques peut-être tellement de noms
qu'on peut après attribuée à tous les
styles
jusqu'à aujourd'hui quelque chose de
chez intéressé par toutes les musiques
l'auxois le rock le blues le funk le
classique ce que je veux aussi parfois
avec des musiciens classiques
j'ai pas vraiment de frontières et le
choix de la musique du jazz pour votre
carrière ça s'est présenté comme une
évidence pour vous au départ c'est plus
l'instrument donc le saxophone qui m'a
dirigé 20 qui m'a amené vers le jazz
mais mes parents écoutaient
beaucoup de musique mais surtout
classique ou alors les beatles mais pas
vraiment de jazz un peu et l'instrument
je sais pas comment il est venu c'est
plutôt par andré popp avec piccolo saxo
je crois est un enfant qui m'a mis la
puce à l'oreille et donc j'ai commencé
vers l'âge de 11 ans et voilà de fil en
aiguille je me suis dit je vais en faire
mon métier et j'ai découvert le jazz
grâce à cet instrument et je suis tombé
amoureux de cette musique et voilà après
c'est parti à parti aujourd'hui vous
produisez un peu partout dans le monde
un peu partout dans le monde dans le
monde là j'étais en italie pour une
tournée il ya deux semaines là je repars
pour une tournée en angleterre après je
pars pour une résidence en suisse vais à
côté de zurich
après je pars au japon après au brésil
voilà c'est sur ce enfin quoi mais c'est
génial
et avec ce prix django reinhardt ce que
vous espérez peut-être avant une
autorité plus grande en france ici ce
qui est sûr c'est que nationalement ça
va peut-être faire un petit peu plus
bouger les choses jeu c'est vrai que je
tourne énormément à l'étranger peut-être
même plus que notre territoire national
mais même si je tourne énormément mais
plus dans le cadre des clubs
peut-être moins des festivals et là je
vois que ça va commencer déjà un peu
faire évoluer les choses et
voilà toute façon en france je suis
amené à jouer dans beaucoup de régions
et d'être invité dans beaucoup de
d'événements très différents donc voilà
c'est sûr que ça va booster un peu le la
carrière autre écueil terme de sorties
d'albums il ya ce dernier album drilzane
connection c'est quoi votre actualité en
ce moment alors il ya ce disque est
sorti l'année dernière qu'avec un
fabuleux batteur américain alient
jackson qui est le batteur de wynton
marsalis qu'avec qu'il a officié dans le
big band de wynton marsalis lincoln jazz
jazz center pendant dix ans maintenant
il habite à toulouse donc c'est
intéressant on peut l'appeler plus
souvent c'est un batteur au delà que ce
soit un très bon batteur il distincts
extrêmement c'est un musicien énorme qui
vous inculquer vraiment de jouer du jazz
c'est à dire écouter les autres
l'humilité et voilà la communication au
piano c'est un brésilien puisque je suis
amené à jouer là-bas régulièrement et on
fait de disque là bas s'il est des
cariocas c'est-à-dire habitants de rio
rio de janeiro il s'appelle eduardo frei
s est donc notre bassiste le plus
français des américains qui habite en
france depuis des année s'appelle darwin
rôle et avec qui je vais jouer le 25 et
26 avril au sunside d'ailleurs et on
retrouve tout votre actualité sur le
site internet il ya d'abord un ya
d'ailleurs on va un arrive à la fin de
cet entretien et quatrième album en
préparation justement qui va se faire à
rio de janeiro c'est ça alors à rio je
vais enregistré avec des musiciens
brésiliens et ce sera le nouveau projet
même s'il ya beaucoup d'autres projets
qui sont en cours mais ce sera le je
dirais que c'est le projet qui me tient
à coeur le actuellement et ensuite tout
votre actualité je le rappelle sur votre
site internet merci baptistère danse est
repassé sur ce plateau saxophoniste
professeur de saxophone de jazz à
rambouillet de jazz pardon et vous est
le lauréat du prix django reinhardt
la 21e édition du printemps des poètes a
commencé mercredi avec pour thème cette
année la beauté à saint quentin en
yvelines un premier atelier s'est tenu
hier à la médiathèque du canal à
montigny le bretonneux
mélanie poké il ya assisté marylène
iapichino vous le raconte tout en poésie
interprétation poétique en musique une
entrée dans l'univers de la poésie pour
tous sans besoin d'études de sémantique
le printemps des poètes vous plonge dans
toutes ses fantaisies cet après-midi-là
atelier vient on va voir des poètes
on propose un temps de scène ouverte
voilà chacun vient adultes enfants
adolescents lire un texte qu'il a envie
de lire une vingtaine de lieux sont
investis sur l'ensemble du festival une
quarantaine d'intervenants pour vous
faire aimer la musique du langage des
mots qui partent à l'international et
permet au public saint quentinois un peu
de vagabondage monfils qui a des
origines marchiennes s'est demandé si le
raconteur d'histoires par les marocains
parce qu'il ya des freins la station de
son qu'il a reconnus du marocain c'est
très inattendu je ne m'attendais pas du
tout à ça et je juge très surprise et
très touché des amoureux de la poésie
passionnés qui vous plonge dans leur
univers inspiré ce que nous proposons
par menant changement de la musique
et puis l'enchantement des gens qui sont
autour de nous c'est vraiment ce retour
aux origines de cette rencontre entre la
poésie l être humain des rencontres
poétiques sous toutes ses formes la
commanderie accueille le tout premier
village du mot le dernier week-end pour
terminer en grande forme performance
conférences expositions et ateliers vous
pouvez vous le notez au mime ou
beethoven expliqué aux enfants comme
chaque année l'association pour la
promotion de la musique classique à
saint quentin en yvelines organise des
concerts à la merise attrape deux jours
huit représentations pour les solistes
de lavilledieu destiné aux élèves de
l'agglomération mélanie poquet
[Musique]
pas de concert consacré à beethoven
cinquième symphonie le compositeur
allemand est au coeur de ces nouveaux
concerts pédagogiques de la pms q comme
son concerto pour violon en ré majeur
c'est un concerto absolument magnifique
d'une part qui permet de mettre en
valeur lors qu'être la soliste parce que
aussi c'est un une musique qui est un
petit peu universel au même titre que
bach que mozart et beethoven si on
demande à un public non averti de citer
un nom de compositeur il ya de fortes
chances pour qu'il cite beethoven mozart
bach
une oeuvre qui fait vraiment partie du
répertoire parce qu'on passe qu ils
peuvent avoir accès à ce répertoire à la
et puis en fait eh ben c'est petit à
petit que les choses se font les enfants
reviennent ils ont une culture musicale
et après ben c'est un chemin qui est
tracé cette année près de 4000 enfants
assisteront à ces concerts pédagogiques
45 minutes de musique pourront aussi
découvrir les instruments tétant
d'histoire de géographie et d'art
travailler en amont dans les écoles on
prépare un dossier pédagogique très très
fouillée très travaillé avec le chef
d'orchestre là la soliste et nous mêmes
les enseignantes ont ce dossier et en
plus maintenant avec les tableaux
pédagogue pédagogique ils peuvent
écouter la musique ils peuvent passer
des enregistrements ou envoient un
orchestre un concert que les enfants
pourront revivre en famille à les
solistes de lavilledieu seront à nouveau
sur la scène de la mairie ce samedi 16
mars accompagné des maîtrises de trappes
et de rambouillet
[Musique]
voilà c'est la fin du set 8 journal
édition complète et ainsi que tous les
reportages à retrouver sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile
restez avec nous pour l'émission 7,8
loisirs marylène iapichino vous donne
des idées de sorties pour ce week end
c'est dans un instant belle soirée avec
tv 78
[Musique]